hello everyone my name is Michael Altos
from motor clothes calm and welcome
today's presentation on how to identify
market turning points as they happen
using order flow now what do I mean by
market turning points I mean areas where
the market goes from a demand driven
market to a supply driven market or vice
versa a supply driven market to a demand
driven market and that's where you're
gonna get some great profit potentials
so my goal for you today is to explain
new developments in order flow analysis
to show you what you need to know about
using order flow to see market turns and
we teach you to trade what you see
happening in the market and the last
thing we'll share with you a high
percentage order flow trade setup now if
this is your first time watching one of
my presentations if you stick around to
the end I have a special gift for you
it's a hundred fifty page book called
trading order flow that I wrote and
you're not gonna get the actual
hardbound copy what you can get is the
link to download the PDF version so you
can put it on your phone put it on your
tablet download it to your computer
print it up do whatever you want so
those of you that are first-time
listening to me I just want to briefly
briefly explain Who I am and the reason
I'm doing this is so you understand my
background and you can see that you know
I come from a real trading background
not somebody that's just been trading in
Sim I've been trading and in real life
this is what I did for a living you know
at an institutional level and now you
know I'm teaching you the same methods
that I used in my career so for the last
three years I've been running order
flows calm but prior to that I spent
eight years at JPMorgan or as vice
president of futures trading and this
wasn't like I was sitting in some corner
office just looking at risk spreadsheets
no I sat on the trading desk I was a
trader and you know I come in the office
at 5:00 in the morning leave at 5:00 at
night and pretty much any futures
contract that was open that's that's
what I traded I spent three years at
Commerce Bank as a licensed Eurex trader
and that was in the time when you know
the electronic trading was just starting
up and to actually have a UX terminal
you had to pass this very intense exam
put out by the exchange to become a
licensed UNIX trader and I traded
everything in Europe in oh sorry I knew
your ex you know you got buns bobble
shots
Dax Euro stocks and I traded them
against you know the US counterparts on
the e-mini is the
Tan's fives two years I spent four years
at Cargill on their trading desk and
eventually they when Sam acts in
Singapore closed down their trading
floor they sent me out to Singapore to
set up their trading desk out there
their futures trading desk it's been two
years with EDF man the English trading
company as a global macro trader and I
started on the seamy floor with Dean
Witter I started out as a runner you
know I started out at the bottom and
nowadays you know there's no more
trading floor so you can't just go down
and get a job and get entry into the
industry the way you used to be able to
now it's it's very difficult you have to
have like a certain background come from
a certain University you know no
computer programming and it's a shame
because you know there's some probably
some brilliant traders out there that
will never get that opportunity to start
trading because the the the barrier to
entry has shifted a lot and I left the
floor and I worked on the trading desk
at Dean Witter the off the floor trading
in essence what they used to call those
desks at those times as globe expose
just starting up you in Globex from cme
and project day from war to trade yet
nymex access from nymex slash comics and
that was in the early 90s when you know
electronic trading was just starting up
and i really saw the futures as that's
where I wanted to position myself to be
going forward so you know that's just
gives you a brief background of who I am
you know it's about 20 years of real
life Futures Trading experience you know
it's not something where you know I just
sort of diddle around on the weekends
back-testing anything no you know this
is what I did to survive is what I did
to pay my bills you know pay for my
house pay for my car everything paint
eat you know it's not like I had another
job then I'd go home and look at charts
no this is that was my job trading so in
2013 I left JP Morgan I spend more time
with my family and trade on my own you
know that's the beauty of trading is it
gives you that freedom to do what you
want with your life and I had gotten to
you know my early 40s and I just
realized I spending way too much time in
the office i spending more time in the
office then you know with my my wife and
daughter and i just know that you know
that's not what i want to do for the
next 20 years you know I've had
colleagues literally die on the trading
desk you know one lady had an aneurysm
she's
desks 20 feet away from mine another guy
in wasn't also in Singapore I had a
heart attack on the trading desk and you
know even at Cargill are the guy that
ran Cargill Singapore I wasn't feeling
good he went to the hospital hospital
fortunate it was like a block away from
from our office and had a heart attack
right at the front door for the hospital
you know I didn't want to get to that
point where a social dress because I was
killing myself or for a company you know
when when it doesn't have to be that way
you know if I could you know trade for
myself make enough money to be happy and
you know cover everything that's great
that's what I want to do then I started
writing my book trading order flow and I
was trading with the volume footprint
chart at the time as well but you know
the volume footprint chart that was
available just it was a basic volume
footprint chart that's all it was
nothing special and you know I know that
there's certain types of analysis that I
do certain things I look for in the
order flow and I wanted to have software
that can do that for me and I said you
know there's nothing like that out there
on the market at that time so I sat down
I found a programmer who's familiar with
order flow and volume footprint charts
and we sat down and I said hey can can
we do this he says I'll sure you can you
know it's a computer you could pretty
much have it do whatever you want so
okay I give him my instructions and we
want to work on it for a couple months
and it came back with the order flow
straighter and that was the first
version which you know you can see price
rejection price support absorption and
other little market nuances now it runs
on ninjatrader so you know and then this
ninja trader good yeah it's alright it's
not bad especially if you're a newer
trader you know you got some order
routing going through there but you know
the for as far as a programming
standpoint it's you know for my
programmer that's that's what a
specialty was and that's why we ended up
on ninjatrader he was on a TradeStation
guru then a probably on tradestation but
it's on ninjatrader eight ninja trader
seven the original version but most
people are on ninjatrader eight now
which is a new version and going forward
that's what their ninja trader is going
to support so what I'm presenting here
is what I've developed for myself and
built my trading career on I hope you
can I find things that you can use or
things you can modify and adapt for your
own trading again yeah I'm not trying to
turn you into a clone of me you know I'm
not saying
you have to trade like this no you know
if something doesn't resonate with you
as a trader don't use it you know every
traders mentality is different you know
whether it's on risk or you know when
you have position going against you you
know person a could probably take a
certain amount of heat person B could
take more heat person C could take even
more heat than a and B put together and
you have to find yourself a bit as a
trader you know trading I have to say
you know some cliche but trading is a
journey and you have to go down
different alleys find what works for you
what you're comfortable with and go from
there you know it's not like you know
it's think of it like dating right
there's a lot of pretty women out there
and sometimes you think all the woman so
pretty she wants be perfect then you
know you go out with her and you find
out she's got no personality she's awful
even though she looks good but you know
in trading it's the same way you know
you could find a method that has a high
percentage but if it doesn't suit your
personality it's probably not gonna work
I'll work for you so you know I'm not
saying you have to follow what I say
just because I say it you know you see
this so many times on online and in
these forums you know people say no you
have to trade this way then when you
question them you get shot down and
called in all sorts of nasty names and
then their buddies come in and pile in
on you and you know and really I mean
who do you want to take advice from you
know somebody that just posts
occasionally on a message board under
the name fat lips 22 or you know someone
with a real trading background you know
not online it's very anonymous you know
I put myself out there you know you see
Who I am you see my background and you
know I'm not hiding behind a keyboard in
the sense that you don't you know an
anonymous person anonymous source and
you have to take that in consideration
when you listen to people as far as
trading it evaluate everything you come
across from me or elsewhere and decide
if it will help you you know if not you
know just rejected so you know let me be
clear you'll have to make trading
decisions that's what trading is about
it's not necessarily about taking red
light green light signals I mean you can
you know as long as you understand it
you know and that's where a lot of
people go wrong is they don't understand
the method that they're training and you
know the bias system red light green
light system
and it fails you know as a couple losing
trades then all of a sudden now they're
gonna start trading the trading system
and looking for trades that they think
for whatever reason is going to be
successful as opposed to unsuccessful so
you know that's not how do you have to
understand what's happening in the
market and once you understand order
flow it's gonna allow you to view the
market in ways you haven't before now
before I jump into the whole
presentation let me let me just say a
brief disclaimer because you know I want
people understand there is a risk
involved in trading in this presentation
is for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a futures contract or make any other
type of investment decision futures
trading contains substantial risk it's
not for every investor and investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk Apple is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessary indicative of future results
now you know in the trading software
world you know there's different types
of trading software out there there's
some that are made by programmers well
they're all programmed by programmers
but you know there's some that are
specifically designed by programmers
with very little trading experience and
then there's others that are obviously
designed you know programmed by a
programmer but the force behind it is a
traitor okay and what the difference is
well once a programmer you know the
mentality for programmers are to solve a
problem okay say I want to create a
software that will give the trader a
volume footprint chart and then they do
that and then that's it they say well I
accomplished that whereas you know a
trader who's trading and uses the tools
on a daily basis will create the
software you know work with the
programmer hey great this program for me
create this volume footprint chart for
me throw in these tools okay that's done
okay you sit back then you start
thinking how can I improve it so do you
want a software that hasn't been
improved in five years or a software
that's you know being improved every so
often you know you should want the one
that's being improved and you know
adding new features over time as opposed
to one that just was created and then
that's it you know no new advancements
and you know like I said I was using the
volume footprint chart in 2013 and when
I go look at it now in 2018 it's the
exact same thing
there's been no additions to it
whatsoever and when the only addition is
they went from nt7 to mt8
but that's it you know I mean that's not
what I would want as a trader you know
it's it's about innovation and and taken
you know new new discoveries so to speak
or new ways of analyzing the market
that's gonna give you an edge you know
if you're using something that has been
around for many years and it's just you
know just the basic thing it's not gonna
give you much edge over other traders
and you know the order flows trader was
designed by a trader for traders and we
keep releasing new tools for traders
based on the analysis done by traders
you know you should want a system that's
designed by traders for traders as
opposed to the system designed by a
program thinking well this is what
people want and there's a couple of
other versions out there someone create
the same thing in sell for a cheaper
price or more expensive price it's you
know that's not what you want you want
something that's being used by traders
for trading and the tools that I put
into illustrator are tools that I
developed in trade from I mean these are
ideas concepts sort of speak foreign so
analysis however you want to say it that
used to do in my head when I was be
looking at the volume footprint chart
and you know that was my goal was to
take what I do my thought process and
put it into the program so it will
highlight to me where potential buying
and selling opportunities appear and why
is that important because that gives me
the opportunity to broaden my horizons
you know broaden how many markets I'm
looking at if I could have you know six
charts you know six screens you know
it's a different chart on each screen
but I can see on one chart it's given me
a signal and other charts not rather
having to flip through a lot of things
and keep constantly scanning you know my
resources and my brain are better served
that way so first I'll talk about is the
new developments in order flow analysis
and I said you know we released the
order flows trader 2.0 about a you know
six weeks ago more or less and what
we've added into it were prominent point
of controls market sweeps multiple
imbalance and added enhanced trap
traders
which is you know takes what we had in
the initial or a flows trader which was
the trap trader so what we did is we we
added an extra way to view it in their
extra way that it's going to be
highlighted in the software single
prints order flows divergence and ratios
now you know it's funny because the
ratios you know that that that tool that
I have in my software that I added in
the initial version was you know it's
it's a number that appears above or
below the bar and if it's above a
certain ratio or below a certain ratio
it's a number that I like in the sense
that you know price rejection or price
support and you know so it's been copied
by other software out there and and fine
you know I knew kind of wish to just
give me credit for it but still you know
they look the part that that chides me
is you know they call it some fancy name
like I've seen order flow Algol or
something like that it's just nonsense
and you know it just makes me laugh but
you know the original users of my
software people have been trading order
flow for years and I've had my software
since its first release I mean there are
people that buy literally everything on
order flow that comes out they know you
know cuz I get the emails from people
saying hey you know this software is
adding your ratios or the software is
adding that and it's it's it's quite
funny but in in the sense that you know
they try to pass it off as some new
development that they discovered when
they haven't and you know the order
flows divergence you know basic order
flows divergence is as simple it's it's
a new or equal high with a negative
Delta or new equal though with positive
Delta but what makes our order flows
divergence different is that it takes
price action into account and yeah
that's important because if you if
you're trying to trade a reversal right
when you have a divergence you're
looking for the market to if it's rally
then you got divergence you looking for
the market sell-off if the price action
in the bar doesn't confirm it then it's
got a high high chance of failing so you
know that's the difference between our
order flow the divergence and which is
free and our software yet there's
there's other software companies selling
it that would just that one indicator
for five hundred dollars which is just a
basic one and all it is it's just when
you have a new or equal high with
negative Delta or a new equal low with
positive Delta there I just saved you
500 bucks you know if you
different different software so let me
explain some of these new developments
here are tools that we have in the order
flows trader prominent opponent controls
now every bar has a point of control and
what point of control is in the bar it's
the area with the most price volume and
volume footprint charts you know they
will put a box around it you know sort
of shaded in a little bit just to
highlight it and what a problem opponent
control is it's the point of controls
that based on my analysis I have found
to be important and they often act as
support and resistance now why is that
important is because when you know areas
of potential support or resistance you
can take advantage of them when market
reaches those prices again so how does
it appear so again like I said every bar
has a point of control the ones that are
supportive you know I color in with cyan
color kind of an aqua blue color the
ones that are resistance have a you know
sort of a magenta pinkish color okay and
you can see how oftentimes you know they
act as support or resistance you know
lots of times I could show you tons of
charts where the market just literally
reacts right off those levels it's it's
it's a scary but you know that's you
know when you have supporting resistance
that's what happens
okay now sort of allude to the second
point I was talking about when you know
that there's support or resistance you
could also play for pull backs towards
those points and you can see here you
have a supportive point of control here
in this prominent point of control where
is the market eventually you know it
sort of goes sideways trades right back
down to that point of control rallies
right up to the sub resistant supported
control comes off rallies right back up
to that point of control and sells off
so you know if you're someone you know
who has a trading plan that
likes to look for you know buying
opportunities on pull backs to support
if you know the first time you hit that
level you have support down here
you trade there you know you could throw
in a bid at that level you know your
stop is just two or three ticks away
it's not like you're gonna have a twenty
tick stop you know you're if the support
level breaks down you should be out of
the trade you know if you're right at
this point of control you probably would
not have gotten your only three Lots
traded that the market rallied up here I
hit this resistance and you know okay
you could throw an offer right there you
know you have to stop two or three ticks
away
this one you would have been filled cuz
he went bid over here so if you got an
offer here at nine and a half you know
it was nine and a half bid so you
technically it'd be filled and you know
nine and a half all the way down you
know in this bar down to two you know so
that's this is euro currency so that's
what is that like 16 and a half tix
right there you know so there's
different ways you can play the
prominent opponent controls I know there
are some traders I know that just look
for prominent important controls that's
what their whole trading plan is built
around now market sweeps market sweeps
are areas where big traders sweep the
market you know buy or sell through
several price levels in one trade and
you know this happens more than people
realize and you know it's funny because
you never spend any time in message
boards you'll see people say well
there's no such thing as sweep why would
anybody buy through the offer price well
they've never traded more than two
contracts if they say that because you
know I know this for a fact because I
used to trade big size when I was
working at these firms and you know if I
got 500 lots of crude oil to buy and
there's only 10 Lots on the offer 25 on
the next offer 15 on the next offer 50
at the next offer and so on I got 500 to
buy and I want to get it done now there
may be icebergs on some of those offers
on the way up I might buy it five cents
through the offer price and turn it bid
that's what's called a market sweep and
I hate to say but you know I think it
occurs a bit more on the need the New
York markets 9mx Comex because it sort
of goes back to you know understanding
that you know their system their initial
trading system the 9x access system
actually had a function on there called
the sweep function where you can sweep
through the market so say you had 100
lots of gold to sell you could see the
depth of the market there and you just
sort of toggle down your quantity you
know you go okay it's whatever 1260 to
50 bid and you can see down to 1260 to
10 bid there's 120 you just enter your
quantity and boom it'll sell it down 100
contracts down to 1260 to 10 for you and
it does happen your honor
sometimes people know no one's gonna buy
through it you know they do people do
you don't understand how traders work
when
you know people that say no no one buys
through the offer it happens a lot it
happens a lot then I'll show you you can
see it on the order flows trader
software you know put an arrow I think
I'm gonna call it is different because I
have trapped traders and market sweeps
is kind of the same colors it's
different tones
the salad market is just sort of going
sideways here then a big sweep comes in
here someone sweeps the market right
before the market sells off and when do
sweeps happen is because somebody thinks
something is about to happen maybe they
got some information that hasn't hit the
market yet you know or you know whatever
it doesn't matter maybe a big order came
through the trading desk and you know
they got to get it done quickly that's
why people sweep the market hey you go
market Sweeps here you know this is
crude oil this time before I showed you
Nasdaq the previous chart that was NQ
this is CL and you see it's marketing we
hit the low got a prominent controls
start rallying up got a red candle here
well is it going down or is it gonna go
back up well well I get an indication of
a market sweep here and a rallies right
back up now you know give you an example
of why people you know use the sweep why
people sweep through the market you know
there's information like I remember back
in the 90s I used to talk to this trader
at Koch Industries guy was based in
London he was a metal straighter on the
LME floor and you know he traded copper
and I'm actually the knight Mexico Maxim
access you know had copper on there and
it was a 645 you get the inventory
numbers there in the LME coming out and
you know we'd be there talking on own we
see these numbers coming out on Reuters
at right at the time and you know would
be ready with our systems to sweep the
market either up or down you know a
whole handle either direction for
whatever you know 100 Lots and you know
at that time 100 Lots in copper was
considered a lot but because we know how
then the numbers gonna affect the market
but we don't know what the number is so
we're waiting for the numbers soon as it
hits that not many people are really
paying attention to it cuz they know
they got a call there brokers you know I
was fortunate I had an IMAX access
machine right on my desk so I could do
it so as soon as the number came up boom
I can hit it hit the enter button so
that's that's how you use market sweeps
and people use it a lot
people sweep the market but it's only
the big traders that sweep the market if
you're a small retail trader you're not
gonna sweep the market because you know
you're just trading you know five Lots
maybe ten Lots but you know if you're
trading 100 lots 200 lots 300 Lots
you're gonna sweep the market at times
just because there's no liquidity there
now multiple imbalances it's three or
more imbalances in a bar now if you're
not familiar with an imbalances it
occurs when there's an buying you know
more buyers and sellers more aggressive
buyers and sellers by a ratio of four to
one or more aggressive sellers and
buyers also by four to one four to one
seems to be the industry standard I know
some people that use 1000 as their
imbalance and they have the whole
trading plan built around that it really
depends on you but you know I stick to
400 now what a multiple imbalance is
it's similar to a stacked imbalance okay
now stacked imbalances when you have
three or more imbalances stacked one on
top of each other and that's nice it's a
visual thing I get it but multiple
imbalances is when there's three or more
imbalances in the bar that are not
necessarily stacked on top of each other
and it's very important actually
so you give you a visual visual look at
it so what you have here right off this
loan where the market starts railing up
off this prominent point of control you
have a multiple imbalance okay further
up here you have a stacked imbalance and
then bounces neatly stacked on top of
each other you have this nice a zone
drawn out but here you just have one two
three four imbalances on a eight range
chart which there's about nine price
levels so you know 45% of the bar is is
aggressive buying buying imbalances 18
against 73 against 29 against 131 0
against 31 these are all imbalances now
let me ask you where would you rather be
getting long down here right off this
low where you see the aggressive buyers
coming in with the multiple imbalances
in the bar or you know that's at 70 to
55 or you're gonna wait until it gets up
to 70 to 75 where you got a stacked
imbalance to get long well again would
rather get long at 55 or it's 75 that's
20 ticks of extra profit you're giving
up by just keying in on stacked
imbalances and you know that could make
or break your trading day you know
between you know 26
and you know it happens more often than
they're not and you know there's another
example crude this is a one-minute chart
this time you know we're just sort of
come down into this bond we got this
bottom forming you know when you come
down it's like a plane landing you know
it's a gradual gradual coming in knots
getting ready for takeoff which when I
look for signs is you know are we going
higher and you're just hanging around
this low you know the plane is landing
boom boom boom
okay now let's get ready for takeoff
again because what's happening is you're
at this low buyers are being attracted
by the low prices they're coming in you
know the bigger traders are seeing it
hey you know it is a good price here
sixty four seventy sixty four sixty six
on get in and they get aggressive they
start buying it and boom the market
rallies and if you're looking for a
stacked imbalance you got no stacked
imbalance down here you're gonna miss
that trade completely okay there's
another example euro currency okay you
hit your high you know you have a
divergence here this one fails it fails
in the sense that you need a new high by
four ticks then you get up here to this
new high you have a primary point of
control which is also bearish and you
get here you got another divergence but
what else you got you got a stack
I started multiple imbalances no static
selling imbalances here you got one two
three three imbalances right off this
high you know aggressive selling is
coming in off this high earlier you knew
you had resistance selling as well so
you up here at this high and you just
I'll see in signs of selling coming in
if you look at the Delta it's mostly all
negative Delta except there's one bar
with small positive Delta 15 but overall
it's all negative you know what would
you rather be doing think of them you're
gonna think the markets gonna get go
higher I think the markets gonna sell
off all signs are pointing that this
markets getting ready to sell off
alright so you know that should cover
some of the newer developments that
we've made in the order flows trader and
next time I'm talking about is what you
need to know about using order flow now
to see the market turns and the market
turns are areas where the market shifts
from demand driven market to supply
driven market and vice versa and I said
you know I said earlier these are areas
that offer a tremendous profit potential
with manageable risk now you know if you
think oh my gosh she done lost supply
and demand
you know economics no it's simple when a
market is demand-driven there's people
are interested in buying and prices go
higher if it's supply driven there's a
lot of supply on the market there's a
lot of inventory and prices go lower
because in order to sell that excess
inventory they got to lower their price
think of it in regular terms you know
the used-car lot
or not the new car lot for that sake you
know when the new Corvette comes out
there's a lot of demand for it you know
everybody wants it but you know a year
later once the demand has been met and
you know Chevrolet has been making a lot
more Corvettes I was suddenly the car
dealers got a lot of Corvettes on his
lot that he can't get rid of so he's got
to start lowering the parties become a
supply driven market because he's got a
lot of supply and he's got a lower lower
lower the price to get rid of the cars
think of these things in everyday terms
and it becomes a lot easier so primary
opponent controls again you know how I
talked about how the markets just react
you know we sell off from a primary
point of control then we rally from one
then we sell off from another one you
know that that's nice it's beautiful
when it happens like that doesn't always
happen that way but you know there are
it happens more often than I can show
you charts you know but just you know
when it happens you know be happy that
it happens that way but it's a great
tool it's a great tool and again you
know were you gonna be placing your stop
on something like this it's just behind
the highs you know need at authentic
stop 26 top you know your point of
control is you know say one 18:08 you
know your stop is up here at 118 10 you
know four tix five you know I wouldn't
do five ticks but you know for ticks I
think is plenty because if you violate
that high then you know the reason for
being in the trade is not there again if
you like to play pull backs you know you
got your primary point of control you
sell off a little bit rally right back
up to that parameter put control I'll
then sell off you know so rather you
know there's two ways to play it one you
could be aggressive because sometimes it
doesn't pull back but you know if you're
a patient and you want to play a
pullback you know that's what I talk
about this all I talk about the low rich
trade you got an offer sitting right in
here you know at 47 24 647 yeah you
catch the move down to this other
prominent point control down here
at 27 you know and we rally back up to
where that prominent point of control
sell off to the primary port of control
rally back up like that it's almost like
a pinball machine
yeah ping pong ping pinball turn I'm
trying to use exceed in here you know
okay you got this little sideways action
here then you hit this low rally up you
got this high brown opponent control
sell-off from there you know and where
do you rally you rally right back up to
that pronghorn control and sell-off now
multiple imbalances now they can occur
anywhere but when you take them in
context of what's happening in the
market it's gonna make it more effective
you know that's where a lot of traders
go wrong is they don't take trades in
context sometimes they say well you know
I got a signal here I gotta take it just
because there's a signal there well when
you take trades in context of the market
that's what I talk about being a trader
you have to understand what's happening
in the market you know things have
become a lot easier for you now here you
have a multiple buying imbalance here
you have a multiple selling balance now
the market just rallied okay in multiple
buying balance do you want to buy can
the market go higher yes of course it
can but your profit potential can be
limited you know I said if we just had a
big rally and I start seeing signs that
the market is turning and I see a sign
you know aggressive sellers coming in in
the form of multiple selling imbalance
then I wanna get short you know I'm not
going to look in the beginning long and
I could see it here the market rally
primary point of control came here maybe
new high by a couple ticks another prime
important control now I see multiple
selling imbalance coming in yeah it's
time for me to get short you know I
wouldn't be thinking that we're gonna
rally back up maybe make a new high the
potential for it to go too short
potential for profits on a short side I
think far outweigh the profits on the
upside as you can see it's getting heavy
up here there's a lot of supply up in
here there's no reason to think that
it's going to continue this rally higher
now multiple in bounce again you know
the reason why I added multiple
imbalances is because in order flow
you're taught to look for stacked
imbalances you're taught to look for you
know the the shaded color in area and if
you do that you're going to miss the
multiple imbalances and again you know
it's important because you know if
there's a lot of imbalances
in a bar even though they're not stack
doesn't mean it's not important it's
important information and it's
information that very few people are
even using you know all these we talk
about trading you know I always Jonah
says you have an edge you have to have
an edge and that gives you an edge over
traders you mean if you have the
information that's available and you're
using it in your trading and nobody
else's a very very very few other
traders are using it that's going to
give you an edge over them yeah that's
what you have to understand having an
edges in the market is having something
that other people don't have you know
and it's not inside information this
information is available to anybody that
has software but you know do you want to
use it or not you know do you think it's
important or not now here's a great
example point a point B Point C point a
multiple imbalances point B also
multiple imbalances was a stacked in
balance point see multiple imbalances
but on the downside so let me ask you
point A to point B where would you
rather be getting along point a of
course you know you'd rather be getting
along 2792 then oh my gosh I got stacked
and balanced up here 2797 I get long you
get long but you're met with you know
very bearish bar up here you got a
bearish ratio you have trapped traders
you have also a divergence you end a new
high with negative Delta so even if you
got long here you're gonna get out you
can get stopped out most likely if you
don't get out on your own and then in
the next bar you got multiple imbalances
multiple aggressive sellers coming in
and the market sells off so again if
you're only looking at stacking balances
you only see this you don't see this
great buying opportunity down here you
don't see this great selling opportunity
up here you just take your loss here and
say all multiple imbalances don't work
well or buy stacked imbalances don't
work yeah you know because you're not
using all the information that's there
for you and you know it just boggles my
mind sometimes you know people aren't
interested in using that because for
whatever reason they think order flow is
you know some sham it's just taking the
data that's available to everybody you
know this is information that what if
lows been around for a long time and
I'll go into the history of it but if
you go back to you know the 1920s
all these guys standing around with
their hats on and their top coats
looking at the vacuum tube with a sheet
of paper coming out the ticker tape that
was order flow in a sense that was a
crude form of order flow now with the
advent of computing power it's really
gotten more powerful so here you got
monthly a bunch of things going on in
here so I talked about how order flow
allows you to see things you normally
wouldn't see or make it more clearer for
you when you're trading you come down
here to a swing low primary point of
control okay then next bar two stacked
imbalances got multiple imbalances you
know and you should be able to notice
the stacked imbalances but this is
interesting cuz it's double stacked
imbalance then you've got a market sweep
as well so you got three things in the
order flow telling you how you get long
this low is most likely gonna hold
because you got you got supported by now
you got aggressive buying coming in get
long you know and you'll be rewarded
from it from you know the mid 40s all
the way up to 80 and multiple imbalances
now here you just you have this
prominent point of control in this bar
great but you also got multiple
imbalances you got four imbalances in
there okay this one took a bit this one
sort of went sideways before taking off
but you know the signs were there you
know when you can start adding together
some of the other pieces of order flow
it just becomes you know trading becomes
much easier now you know that that leads
me into the third thing I will talk
about is trade what you see happening in
the market and you don't try to predict
the future
you know that's just trade based on what
you're seeing in front of you you know
don't sit here with all these you know
Gartley patterns that formations or
whatever trying to predict the future
now you know if the market is telling
you hey it's great you know aggressive
sellers are coming in here you get short
period that's all you got to do you know
or aggressive buyers are coming in here
or hey you got supported by in here now
now there's dressing fires coming in you
get long don't don't try to complicate
things
you know most most times you know
traders spend a lot of time waiting for
confirmation waiting for confirmation
instead of actually trading I mean what
would you rather do is sit on the bench
or would you rather you know play on on
the pitch you know you want to be
playing you know and if you're sitting
around waiting for confirmation you're
gonna miss a lot of trades and just
because you get confirmation doesn't
necessarily mean
trade is gonna work out any better and
you know we tend as people we can't over
analyze situations rather than confront
them or as in trading trade them you
know you got to take the trains when
they present themselves and it's you
know sports and trading have a lot of
analogies and I remember is the baseball
player
you know the got called up for the minor
leagues and then started playing in
Major League Baseball and you can go up
he's watching the pitches come in
you know man on the shoulder and this is
coach and tell them said hey you gonna
swing the bat or what you know you're
not gonna stay in the majors unless you
you know swing the bats so it's like
that with training you know you got a
you got to have different training plans
to take trades I mean there's you know
people that trade with one trading
method one way of analyzing the market I
think you know you can you do that yeah
you can but you if you leave a lot of
opportunities out there you know it's
like having a store you're gonna sell
one product or you gonna sell multiple
products you know your your chances for
success with that store is gonna be
higher if you have multiple products
that sell as opposed to just selling one
product so supportive buying the first
time marches reaches a swing low so
again you know if you knew the first
time that you have supported buying you
put a bit in here okay for the pullback
down in here to get long and again you
know your stop is just right below here
right below this low by a tick or two so
imagine you know if you waiting for
confirmation for a double bottom or
gotta wait for confirmation further
there's double bottom because that's
what all the books say you gotta wait
for confirmation for a double bottom
well if you know their support in the
market that's where you get long I mean
that's the edge that you know big
traders have is because big traders are
often providing support or resistance in
the market so they know that okay they
know that they're buying down here at
ninety so they could be patient you know
cuz the market they know the markets
gonna probably bounce up a little bit
come back down and they can buy more so
if you're waiting for the market to make
the double bottom and start rallying
you're gonna miss your buying
opportunity down here at ninety you can
get long at ninety two because it's kind
of move away from the double bottom
before you can buy because you know
that's that's what you're taught in all
the trading books so and what's your
profit potential from 92 it only
goes up to 93 and a half so would you
rather get long at ninety or ninety two
as two full points in the SPS you know
that's that's you know what is that in
dollar terms there's a hundred bucks in
dollar terms you're giving up right
there you know and and in this move it
only went from 92 up to 93 and three
quarters so this was the the juicy part
of the trade that if you're waiting for
confirmation you're missing that that
stuff now again you know it's is it
always gonna come in and retrace there
no it's not but it's gonna give you a
nice low risk trade by getting getting
in here you know if it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen then you wait for the
next time it happens
okay so trap traders again this is
another tool here I like again you know
when I talk about taking things in
context again you know trap traders it
reads what's happening in the order flow
so even if the markets going sideways if
there's trap traders it'll put a signal
now where would you rather be getting
long from here down here or you actually
get long here because you this bar would
have to close for you to confirm that
your strap traders there so again long
at 880 or dry they get long at you know
895 that's 15 ticks there and in the Dow
then you got trap traders up here on the
sell side and then market starts coming
off again but again take things in
context so you this is where you should
be keying in on here not so much here
you know I like I like it when you get
sharp move down you get traders coming
in late you know that's what's causing
this happen to happen that's what's
causing the signal to occur is
everyone's coming in late they can oh my
gosh were selling off go make new lows
make those guy get shorted I get
shorting it's short the market stamps
back they're trapped and you know they
got to get out but again you know for
them to be trapped down here the only
time I 100 contracts there's enough
volume in here for them to get out but
it's a great short-term trading tool but
again take it in context of what's
happening in the market market sweeps
you can see it here market it's coming
down into this low hits this low are we
gonna rally gonna sell awful we got a
sweep to the negative side to the
downside right in here you got multiple
imbalances one two then you guys nice
stacked and balanced in there as well
and the market sells off some more so
you know these are the tools that you
know can help your trading if you're not
using them and it's information that's
available if you have the right tools
the
to take that information and put it in a
readable format so last thing I'll talk
about is high percentage order flow
trade setup now we all want a high
percentage trades because that's how
you're gonna make your money right you
can't make money unless you got trades
that pay off regularly and to do that
yet start putting together pieces of
order flow analysis so you can take
advantage of what's happening right in
front of you and you know for those that
have been following me for years know
that I talked about the order flows
divergence and ratio setup it's a very
high percentage trade setup one of my
bread-and-butter setups and it's great
reversals you know it's at highs or lows
of the days and you can see here you
know euro currency right at the high you
can short 1:18 double-o all the way down
into the mid-80s and what am I talking
about is involves two tools of the order
flows trade our primary opponent
controls which is explained earlier the
point of control that's considered
support resistance in the order flow and
the divergence a new equal high with
negative Delta or new equal though with
positive Delta and confirming price
action again you know a lot of the other
order flow tools out there don't have
that extra piece of confirming price
action they just look for a new equal
high with negative Delta or new you cool
low with positive Delta and why you put
these two together is because you know
you're at your high of the day okay you
have a divergence now with the primary
point of control if you're at your high
today
you know there's resistance in there if
there's a there's a resistance prominent
point of control okay your low knew
equal low positive Delta Delta's telling
you that it's positive that you have
aggressive buyers coming into the market
and you have supportive buying in there
which is also powerful to know so you
got to two things that when you put them
together
I call it powerful together and you can
see here emini x' on either day
27:48 we sell down into the you know the
low 40s here you got probably a point of
control and divergence out earlier you
had a ratio and divergence you didn't
get to sell off immediately rallied back
up their primary point of control and
divergence again the market sells off
from the 50 area down into the 40s again
primary point of control divergence
actually got some trapped traders down
here as well at this low and you get a
nice move up from you know the 40s back
up to the little
he's up to the high forties bonds okay
bonds this time primary point of control
on divergence we sell-off from the 20
you know 24 23 all the way down into you
know an area we have a support point of
control down here at 13 14 mini Dow
spirometer point of control divergence
and you know your rally from 25 all the
way up to you know up here where you got
you know above 50 we got the prominent
point of control right there prime
opponent control and divergence this
time 0 currency I've showed you bonds
one side bonds you your currency now
mini Dow e-mini 's a bunch art next and
primary point of control and divergence
you see how the market rallies up from
there you know from the 11798 area all
the way up to the 118 10 area now here's
the buns primary point of control
divergence primary point of control
divergent
no problem opponent control but
divergence and a ratio finally the
market makes it rally or so rally up to
rallies up to the area where you have
the prominent point of control and where
do you place your stop on this you just
place your stop right below those lows
of the day you know one take two ticks
below those lows you don't need a 10
ticks away it's gonna give you a nice
tight stop and you know a stop price so
hopefully by now you can see how
powerful or the full analysis has become
you can don't try to over complicate
trading don't try to make judgments
without sound analysis you know again
it's about taking the information that's
available and using it and if you found
this helpful you really like what I have
to offer it's my order flow is trader
2.0 software training package now
remember you know but overwhelmingly
majority of traders lose their account
in the first year and I think there's an
even higher percentage that lose their
account but most of their account in the
first week by 50 percent of the accounts
in the first week why do you think that
is is they keep trading the same way
that all the losing traders have been
trading before them you know they're not
using the new tools and new developments
in trade analysis that's out there and
you know sometimes I really feel like
they're flushing their money down the
toilet and doing that you know you don't
have to if you learn how to trade learn
what moves the markets not in the sense
that you gotta learn that the
data numbers no you know if you learn to
read the volume that's going through and
it's not like you know you're trying to
learn brain surgery or anything like
that it's it's real it's a lot more
simpler than that
yeah it's gonna make trading a lot more
easier so you know I got to the new
order flows trader 2.0 which is for a
ninja trader 8 it'll run on the free
version so again you know if you don't
want to use you know one of their
brokers to route your orders through
then you know you get that you could use
the software on the free version if you
have say tradestation or say a broker's
front-end you can use the ninja trader
for your charting and it's the value
what you can get is the volume footprint
chart with seven pre-programmed order
flow tools that are discussed in this
presentation now order flows and
ninjatrader initiator has their own
volume footprint charts I think I found
what they call it volumetric bars or
some name like that that's different
than this and even to get that yet
divide $1,000 over version of ninja
trader and normally and you get my chart
template alright which is going to help
you get set up on this cuz you know less
problems a lot of people get a volume
footprint chart they don't know how to
set it up you know it's like getting
furniture from Ikea you know trying to
put together you know a dresser or
something that's complicated as heck
sometimes for you know people especially
if you're not computer literate trying
to figure this out and normally I sell
this for $8.99 just this overflows
trader and again you know if you want to
get like the ninja trader volume
footprint chart which doesn't have any
of these tools in this presentation you
got to get the paid version which is
over $1000 but you know having the order
flow software's one thing next thing is
yeah I know how to use it
alright I provide you a lot of further
education so you know how to understand
order file know what you're looking at
so I give you access to the order flows
training course which normally I sell
for 297 everyday on my website it's 20
lessons it's about 15 hours of video
instruction so it's not like oh this is
what a point of control is and no you
know it's an in-depth it's an in-depth
course on trading order flow but I
realize you know because you're watching
this this video you probably understand
an order flow and you really want to
jump into it with both feet you know
jump in and cannonball it and I'll give
you access to the order flows inner
circle video series now this is just the
videos you don't get the additional
indicator
you get access to all 56 videos I wishes
my advanced order flow tricks tips and
analysis normally I sell these videos
series for 497 but I'm gonna throw it in
there also today when you get the
software because you know I really want
to give you everything that you need to
know about order flow so you can know
that you know I that I know my
basically that you understand I want you
to know what I know and the only way to
do it is that's why I created this inner
circle video series because actually I
wanted to to make video series of you
know my knowledge for my kids so when
they get older if they want to trade
these they have something to go back to
and start from there so when you start
adding this up you know you can see it's
software the training the video series
it's already sixteen hundred you know
over sixteen hundred dollars almost
seventeen hundred dollars but because of
investor inspiration I'm gonna also
throwing something extra I went throwing
this the trader kickstart which is an
additional course it's twelve lessons it
deals with the mental aspect of training
you know why traders fail why try to
succeed how to make a daily routine you
know how to keep a journal and why it's
important to keep a trading journal you
know even if it's just on you know a
simple notebook that you buy at Walmart
it's important to get into a routine and
you know to be successful you know great
athletes have a routine before they
start a game you know before they start
a race they they go through a certain
process and you know as a trader you
have to do that - it's not about sitting
down at your desk five minutes before
the market opens and you know with your
cup of coffee and say okay I'm gonna
start trading you know can you be
successful yeah you can but the chances
are a lot less I mean I there are some
people like that you know I remember
being in school you know I used to study
hard but there would be some kids that
are just for whatever reason they could
just you know have a report - I'd be
there you know I'll typed up and
double-spaced and everything and they
were just write it on their notebook
like an hour before class rip it out of
their notebook don't even tear the the
pieces you know the extra excess paper
off the side hand it in they get an A I
get a B you know I kick myself why why
you know I mean there are people out
there like that that no matter what they
do is everything just turns up roses but
for most people you know trading is a
journey and that's why I created this
kickstart so help you get to where you
want to be as a trader so when you add
all that up together you know it's just
about $2,000 she's 1990 okay but you're
not gonna pay that and I hate to sound
like one of these getting sued knifes
others do you yeah but wait there's more
but no seriously you know I really want
to see your success in the market you
know training is not for everybody and
you know sometimes you know when people
can't make it as a trader they like to
blame other people so that's why I like
to give you as much information as
possible so you can be successful you
know and that's what it is I mean I said
even without the software you put your
hand over the software across this one
out the all this training itself is it's
about a thousand dollars worth of
training and you know I can pay that
it's a one-time payment of $7.99 you
just go to order flows calm /off dot -
dot html' there's no more monthly
payments or other payments to me in the
future now you'll need to pay your data
fees and ninjatrader if you're using a
paid version and ninjatrader of course
but again the software run on the free
version now you know what other people
are saying is you know hey Mike your
order flow straighter software is
remarkably helpful because I can clearly
see now what's happening in the market
like for example who's in control of the
market on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well now go to again
you know trading is not for everybody
and success is very some people will be
more successful than others it depends
on you how much time you want to put in
and do you want to learn or not so again
you'll go to order flows comm slash oft
to HTML it takes you to this page okay
and you scroll down there's a couple
videos on there if you want to learn
more about the software what it can do
you scroll down to the bottom it gets
takes you to this button here I want in
and it takes you to PayPal and it's just
right here you just you can pay through
PayPal it would debit a credit card if
you don't have a PayPal account I don't
get your information I don't want your
information and you know it's processed
by PayPal so you know the reason why you
want to join in order for those today is
because you see the power of order flow
analysis and how it can change your
trading you want to understand what's
happening in the markets and you're
excited to find low-risk trading
opportunities you know you want a life
of freedom and fulfillment I was able to
retire from my job at 44 because of
order flow
trading when I was trading in the banks
now if you stuck around to this point
and I promised you earlier you get a
copy of my book trading order flow go to
the link below order flows calm slash
booked out HTML you have to enter your
email address and confirm it and you'll
be put on my distribution list you know
it's funny people sign up get my book
and then you know when I send an email
about something they complain but you
know there's there's a trade off you
know and this book took me almost a year
to write actually but you know I'm
giving to you for free and you know I
just want to share my information share
my knowledge with you so act now go do
order flows calm slash off to dot html'
and join you know I hope to see you on
the inside and have a great day bye-bye